MVP's were announced yesterday mookie
betts and Christian Yelich winning the
MVPs this is the first season in which
the MVPs came from the teams with the
best record in each league the last time
that happened was 1990 with Rickey
Henderson and Barry Bonds the Brewers
outfielder joining us now Christian
first of all congratulations where are
you today thank you that's a big village
right now where you affect on it were
your parents they lived there were they
affected by the fires yeah I mean the
and again pretty close how a lot of
friends and family that were affected as
well and this is a tough week for
everybody in California Northern
California Southern California and so we
had that shooting down the street so you
really feel for everyone you're thankful
for the first responders because without
them you know definitely been a worse
week what did you see when you got home
the surrounding area that's just a lot
of a lot of black everything's burned
everything's charred
you know but luckily for us for the most
part everything in our neighborhood had
been making it out all right but
unfortunately lot of people can't say
the same
you just feel form you want to do your
part you want to help out as much as you
can and try not blow everybody get back
on their feet
how did you find out that you'd won the
MVP right there live right on the TV you
know to have it in your earpiece you're
doing the show and I only come back from
break we're gonna let you know the
winner is my earpiece was still on and
they're still talking and then asking
everybody to come into the shot and
that's kind of when I that's kind of
when I knew that I won it was cool to
celebrate with friends and family and
just be around all those people that
I've been around since I was really
young and not a big impact on my life
if I would have told you at the
beginning of this season you're gonna be
the MVP what would you've sinned yeah
I'd have called you crazy
I remember Stanton won last year we were
teammates in Miami and he hasn't won an
award and he's from out here as well so
we went celebrated basically year ago to
the day
and
I remember thinking how cool was that he
wanted to pee and it never crossed my
mind I'd actually be in his same shoes a
year later and it's been a phenominal
years with a lot of fun huh we had a
great team in Milwaukee you know I'm
just short of the World Series but I
know this was a great way to basically
end the 2018 baseball season what do you
if you're gonna put your finger on it
what happened in the second half of the
season because you've always been good
with talent but something happened in
the second half of the season where you
just went nuclear yeah you know I think
as a player you're always trying to
improve unless you've done years
probably always looking to learn about
yourself and I think you're constantly
learning your slang what you do when you
do well what you do when you struggle
and you try and make adjustments and
going milli all-star break this year
struggle as a team I wasn't playing the
way I wanted to play and you know it
came back after that four day break he
played the game and then it just felt
good something felt good in the cage and
I was able to repeat it throughout the
second half I was able to repeat that
feeling and have an understanding of
what I wanted to do every night and just
focusing on winning we're in that parent
race and I think I brought the best idea
who's the pitcher had frustrated you
this year oh you know it's for the last
few years it's been it's been Clayton
Richard from uh from the Padres he's got
something about it it's just you know I
don't see a lot of gives me a tough time
and it's probably ought to answer that
everybody would think no yeah it guys
and your answer is not surprising
because I can ask great hitters I could
say who gave you the most trouble and
then they'll tell you somebody and you'd
go I don't even know who that is or you
know certainly not a hall-of-famer so
I'm not I'm not surprised at that but
there's always like a quirk with
somebody's delivery or just you know how
you view them or what the pitches are
you know it just it affects you so I'm
not surprised
I saw where degrom got the other
first-place vote what did you think of
him winning this I own yeah you hear an
unbelievable here and I obviously had
the opportunity to play against
we're both in the NL East and he's got
he's got unbelievable stuff he's a great
pitcher and you know it's just tough
every time he's going to face them so I
was well-deserved he had an unbelievable
year definitely happy for him did you
play other sports growing up I'd played
basketball in football before high
school and then once I got the high
school I just played baseball because
that's what I was best at that's what
all my friends ended up doing and you
know I figured I'd ride it out see how
far we could take this whole thing and I
ended up working out all right did you
grow up a Dodger fan yeah I mean I went
to Dodger Stadium a lot from being in
the area that's just how I learned
baseball my first major league baseball
games were all Dodger games and yeah I
guess you could say I was a Dodger fan
how often do you replay Game seven
against the Dodgers in your head um not
a lot obviously wish it worked out
different you know having a habit at
Game seven at home to go to the World
Series and we basically had everything
lined up to what we wanted it but that's
the thing about baseball just doesn't
work out you know doesn't work I you
think it's going to go all the time but
I was proud of our team proud of what we
accomplished this year it sucked at the
time obviously but we can improve on
that well Congrats as a wonderful season
you flirted with the Triple Crown two
homers shy of leading in that and one
RBI shy as well so great great
performance this year and nearly making
it to the World Series as well great
story Kristen and hopefully your parents
are safe and we appreciate you joining
us thank you I appreciate it that's a
Christian Yelich the Brewers outfielder
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
you